i saw you do an interview with a
bunch of black guys i think it was like
an iheart media i don't i don't recall
and they were asking you how you or
italians got along with the blacks in
your neighborhood do you recall that
interview
um unless you're talking about gangster
chronicles i don't know what it was
called but it was you
in a room uh they were asking you about
relations with uh how you got along with
uh african-americans
i always got along good with them
you know
especially in prison
i got along very well
i'm not racist i'm not anything like
that i don't walk around like in prison
thinking my [ __ ] don't stink so i had
good relationships with people
um i went to gyms i used to spa and i
worked out with black guys and
things so i never had a problem with
black guys you told the story about when
you were in the army that
uh
they were in line given the food
and they were they were calling you boy
and they were like you said the most
racist people were in south carolina at
this point in your life well i i didn't
i didn't pick south carolina i was in
carolina port jackson yeah fort jackson
south carolina
i knew what racist was
in new york i mean i knew what it is
growing up i said when i went down there
and i went to fort jackson south
carolina i saw it in a whole different
light
i never
in new york i never went around where a
black guy couldn't go into the same
bathroom
but down there they had that
so it was really late 60s when was this
in the 60s 64 i got in the 60s
so it was really heavy down there now
probably not
legally but the people some of the
people and i had trouble with a couple
of guys walking on the line
and we were serving he came from the
bronx this black guy
and i heard him call him boy and this
and that
i knew he wouldn't like that
i looked at him but it didn't seem to
bother him then he did that with me
and uh
then he
had told me whip it on me boy
you know and i was putting the stuff in
his tray and stuff i had that long metal
spoon
it started dripping over and i stopped
and he threw it on the table
and he says when i tell you whip it on
me i'll tell you when to [ __ ] stop
i was stunned
so i just whacked him right in the front
with his phone
and then the black guy
jumped over the counter because the
other his friend hit me with the train
the black guy jumped out and we were
fighting a couple of them
and then
the mps came we were like arrested
and
the guy that had mp was a black guy and
he looked at me
and he says you like helping black
people but he thought i jumped in to
help him
it was the other way around
gotcha but i wasn't going to tell him
that so i said well that's the way it is
in new york
and he winked at me so i knew i wasn't
in trouble
and uh
when we
we never were able to serve anymore they
put us in the back we were peeling
potatoes all the time no more spoons for
you no more spoons
it's tough to hurt somebody with a
potato yeah yes you got to throw it at
them versus right and you're not on the
line so you're in the back with a big
drum and peeling potatoes all [ __ ]
day long
so i i never had a problem my
granddaughter is biracial
so
i know about the problem you know i'm
doing a video now i was in
prison and i was with a a biker
this guy mark
he had
long long hair coming down a full beard
he looked like
just he looked like he had all hair his
whole face everything you could hardly
see his face
real racist guy
and uh i'm gonna sell with him
the unit manager was black a black woman
and she said i'm gonna put you in the
cell with him
he's
i'm gonna move you as soon as i can but
put up with it
so she knew he was a problem he's a
white guy a white guy a lot of heroines
look like a [ __ ] uh monkey
and uh so
we have
conversations and stuff and
you know he sees a program with a black
man a white woman he wants to change his
channel he wants to do this he wants to
do that
so i said leave it alone
then this the thing every time i got up
i stepped on potato chips pretzels he
was real dirty
that was my first argument i said bro we
gotta live in here clean it i don't want
this [ __ ] on the floor
so
then one day
when i wanted to watch a program
and he didn't want it he says i know why
you allow this
because your daughter
she likes black people right
i said shut your [ __ ] mouth bro i
told you to stop with the racist [ __ ]
he carried on and then he said yeah
she's got a little [ __ ] baby
i hit him so [ __ ] hard we fought all
night long because it was after we let
go you're in the same cell as this guy
same cell we [ __ ] bashed the [ __ ] out
of each other all night one night holy
[ __ ] got up the next day there was a
spanish guy steve over the next so
yeah sammy what the [ __ ] were you doing
bro
so what do you think i was doing bro i
was [ __ ] fighting all night
my lip is hanging
everything's fine but he was all [ __ ]
up he went to the unit manager
and he told her
she called me in
and uh she said what happened
i said none
she said nothing you know you're all
caught up
the guy told me that you had a fight
with him
so i said not a fight
so she says he said racial [ __ ] to you
right
it could be
don't fight no more
you got i can't move you to herself but
you're going to go back in there
kick his [ __ ] brains in she told me
no [ __ ] i swear to god she says do what
you want but don't finish it just don't
destroy him because he wants to be yeah
i went back in as soon as i got back and
i said listen i apologize for last night
so he put his hand to shake and i
whacked him a [ __ ] child and i said
[ __ ] this i beat his [ __ ] brains in
the next day he went to the
warden beds where he grabbed the wood
and he said i want to be moved this
guy's every [ __ ] night
the one looked at me
you fighting with him
i brought a guy's piece of [ __ ]
he's a liar
he's lying your [ __ ] face looks like
i'm [ __ ] like duckies are bleeding
knuckles are still bleeding yeah how'd
you get out of this i said i do that to
myself bro i do that because i'm stupid
and i'm in jail i do it for myself the
law the warden started laughing he says
all right he says
savvy just slow it down a little bit
so everybody hated this guy everybody
hated him what ended up happening to the
guy did he even make it he you know i
was friendly with a b guys some a b guys
and uh this guy john and he was in the
same unit as being we were in other
units together
and he knew about the fight so this guy
mark was going to leave
they called them marshals in here you're
going to leave i was so happy he was
leaving
so
john called him he says hey mark you
leave it yeah
and he put his hand out
mark grabbed his hand he grabbed his
head and hit him a [ __ ] left so you
can't do nothing because the marshals
are waiting
if you don't leave then you're going to
stay there so he wants to get the [ __ ]
out of here anyway so everybody hated
him this guy jimmy the general was a
made guy
he hit him one day with me
you know that's a funny story because he
was a he was a biker
and he did tattoos
so he's showing me some of the work he
did because i had a ton of tattoos
and uh he shows me and his wife has her
dress up
so you could see the leg in the work
but she has no panties on right and
she's it's up quite a bit
so i said oh my god
i said this is good work bro i'm looking
right at his wife
so
i said jimmy come here bro
look at this mark does beautiful work
look she's okay he's got big chalk look
at that
you know big [ __ ] at a time and it says
take a peek at this there's big [ __ ]
over here
so jimmy comes over looks out he's
laughing mark says let's be careful
that's beautiful work in italian
that's what it means
yeah
so
we tortured him
i beat him up every night
how long did that last i mean it lasted
about a week and then he just got he
just stopped he just stopped he was he
was literally crying stop it sammy
because as soon as the door clicked and
the guard walked away he knew it was
it was like round three round four let's
go again i just wanted to go were you
guys ever like knocked out on the ground
like after being you know hitting each
other so much was it everything i had
the top bunk
so and i had the bottom bunk
so as soon as the guard was still there
locking he would try and jump on the
chair at the desk and boom shoot up onto
the top bunk and i couldn't get him
you know because i if i'm short so as i
step on the chair to try again he would
kick
was he an actual monkey
he was like a monkey but i he would kick
me to it so i couldn't get on there but
i would i would take the kicks back off
a little bit and then you were trying to
drag him off the top oh i dragged him
off the top a bunch of times but he
would hang on to the thing but this is
like this whole body was in the yeah
like you're doing a hell in a cell match
like you're the undertaker yeah but
sammy the bottom line is you guys shared
a cell together like
how do you even sleep you just can't
leave yeah exactly
how do you sleep at the end of the night
if we fight for about an hour we could
both go to sleep believe me
you could both go to sleep if you have
to i mean you're so exhausted and so
beat up yeah you know it's just the
whole day now they locked you at night
now you're battling for an hour hour and
a half banging all over the [ __ ]
place
you know you stop it
you just can't keep going in other words
it's not it's not that i want to kill
them i just want to beat them up let me
ask you at the end of the fight do you
say
good night and then like they don't see
you no no there's no good nights
i mean that's a great question i mean
like they were telling me [ __ ] and then
i would tell them listen tomorrow
because i wanted them out of the cell i
don't want to fight him every night i
said don't tell the unit manager to move
him
i mean you talk about go complain i
don't give a [ __ ] you talk about not
being able to sleep i mean your whole
life man you've lived on the razor's
edge for so long like you do something
you do some work and then you got to
think you know man this is what i just
did could be 25 years if anybody ever
catches me at 25 years of my life any
minute anybody could be a cop anybody
can be undercover any anything that you
speak into can be wired like what you
talk about not being able to go to sleep
like what was it like in the beginning
what was it like you know as you were
moving up the ranks did it ever become
easier did it ever be like well they
haven't caught me yet they're not going
to catch me how did how did you handle
the stress of being in that life i got
caught all my life bro every [ __ ]
thing i ever did just about especially
as a kid i got caught a lot of times
look at my rap sheet i'm arrested 20
[ __ ] times in my life i'm arrested
one time
on a double homicide that i didn't
commit
i got out on bail hundred thousand
dollar bill back then
i came out i got busted
robbing cars and robbing things to pay
[ __ ] lawyers and things and i got
busted a third time had three cases
going at the same exact [ __ ] time in
my life
when i had those cases so i'm busted a
lot of times
you know i just
this
life of mine i seem to be involved in
everything
i was chosen to go on hits that were
literally impossible
the johnny keys hit
the castellano and i was in three mafia
wars
my life just never stopped i don't know
what happened or why
and
i just kept working when did you enjoy
your life like what what was the
happiest phase of your life i always
enjoyed my life my wife my kids
when i went away i had a i bought a farm
when we would go away from the farm
i would get off the highway in jersey it
was creamridge new jersey well the mob
everything was out of my head i smelt
those trees
i was in i was in a different
thing when i went home i shut it down
i had two different lives
and i wasn't just
fighting in
[ __ ] all the time
it happened i think maybe my size
it happened
fights more thinking they could get do
something or get away with things
i fought in the ring i don't give a [ __ ]
if i win or lose the fight when i'm in a
fight i want to hurt you
period and i don't give a [ __ ] if you
win
but you're gonna know
that i fought you're in a fight yeah
you're gonna say bro i beat him up but
i don't want to fight him again
[Music]
that's all i do you know but i don't
back up
from anybody in prison but i don't bully
people and i don't i'm good with people
i'm
you know i i asked patrick i know him a
long time i never beat him up as big as
he is
that doesn't happen yet and it wouldn't
have happened
what are you smiling about it might
happen to you first of all
off camera gerard was upset because adam
was acting a little too hard around
girard yeah he felt safe with sam
he had his muscle here with him yeah but
so for the next uh couple hours i'm i'm
looking right at you drug by tomorrow
lose my number
but sami i guess let's let's restate
change the word uh uh happy
peaceful like if you were to go
think about the most peaceful face of
your life when was it like i'm talking
pure peace and i'm not talking about
when i come home smelling the trees the
kids the family all that stuff i'm
talking pure peaceful
what was that era was it when you were a
kid was it when you were in your team
were you you know a young adult when was
that
no of course when i was a kid i had a
good mother a good father and i had good
friends the neighborhood i played ball i
you know i never did anything
but i was dyslexic and i had trouble in
school
so i think that was my downfall
if you want to call it that i had
trouble in school
you know i told somebody once you see
this paper i told them here read this
paper i'll tell you
read this paper
then i take a blank piece of paper and i
just scribble on it
and i say read that
and you'll tell me i can't read it it's
all scribbling
well that's what this looks like to me
how old were you when you said that when
you showed that well i did that a little
older
but
because people didn't understand it back
then
but school just wasn't for me
you know and kids are cruel in school
when you're they're calling you dummy
they're laughing and this and the other
thing i had a little bit of a temper
especially i like girls they're laughing
they're belittling me in front of a girl
so when after school i break your
[ __ ] ass bro so you wouldn't do it no
more
and i think that's what i learned that
you know
a good swift punch stops the laughing
and stops the joking and whatever if
you're joking as a friend and you're
doing something that's one thing but if
you're trying to belittle me
i don't take that
lightly
and i think that's i got left back in
the fourth grade i got left back in the
seventh grade
and i was in a gang so that was it was
over
that started my life
into a way of crime
now we were in a gang we were like [ __ ]
the mafia i'm not gonna ever be in the
mafia it's us against the world it's all
awesome [ __ ] this isn't what middle
school type of things no this is 16 17.
18 19
i got drafted into the army during the
vietnam war i came out when i was 21
right back into the ramp is in the gang
at 23 the neighborhood was so saturated
with the muffin you couldn't do anything
so and while i was gone most of my
friends hooked up with somebody
so at 23 i hooked up with the columbo
family and i did my first hit
and the rest was history i have
a start button
i don't have a stop button
whether it was business
whether it was the mafia
no matter what it was
and it's until today
there were some young girls who worked
for me i burnt them out
too much work too much drive
um
no no other reason but
i seem to always be like that
i'm just aggressive that way
um
i'm 76
and i'm doing
15 different projects
would you guys
uh mafia states of america
i'm working on a scripted show on a
script
i'm working on a
a possible documentary
um daca series we're talking with people
with i have them on social media i'm
like a social butterfly all over the
[ __ ] place
i don't stop
that's gotta be pretty quiet that's
gonna be pretty wild for you you lived
your whole life trying to keep
everything under wraps and now the
entire world is is snitching on
themselves on the phone all these 16
year olds are taking like snapchats on
themselves at a party we used to try to
sneak in at night so our parents didn't
know we were partying you lived your
whole life in the shadows and now
everything's on front street i know what
i say a lot of times i say that what i'm
doing i got you know 400 000 now
subscribers i have 50 something million
hits on my podcast and my videos
i said
if john got he was alive and be looking
at this he would be so sick he would say
that's what i wanted to be he wanted the
publicity he wanted
he would have loved this
in my opinion because this is what he
was about everything was a show
the way he dressed acted it wasn't goes
in austria me i was under duck i don't
want to see nothing you know the agents
would say what a pleasure it was to
follow sammy when he was the underboss
he'd come out of his office
a t-shirt pair of sneakers he'd go in a
schoolyard with some kids playing
handball
it was so different watching him
than watching some other gangsters you
know playing that gangster role i didn't
do that
low key was for me
now my the role's reversed
i i'm a [ __ ] social butterfly youtube
youtubers
they call me podfather now the power
father
[Music]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you